christophe bernon et sa famille ont
toujours eu le goût du jeu en novembre
dernier ils ont lancé la société jacques
am éditrice de jeux de plateaux et de
jeux de cartes
c'est vrai qu'elle continue on cherche
une idée pour prendre soin de ma fille
et puis anthony vont profiter de faire
un jeu de plateau on retrouve ont
récupéré à wiltz
voilà l'idée comme ça tu vas apprendre a
eu pas mal d'idées qui sont arrivés très
rapidement et puis on s'est viandé ben
pourquoi pas effectivement
camon les produire et essayer de les
vendre leurs articles phares mystère à
poissy un jeu de plateau à partir de 6
ans il ya un objet n'a été volé il ya
une personne qui a volé l'objet il faut
retrouver le duo en fait donc c'est
globalement une sorte de cluedo en fait
sauf que plutôt comme vous connaissez
tous
ça se passe dans un manoir et sert à
nous on l'a fait carrément à l'échelle
d'une ville la partie dure entre 30 et
45 minutes et se joue seul ou en équipe
de 2 à 6 joueurs
l'idée de base c'est quand même de
réunir toute la famille s'est
globalement c'est déjà assez simple il
n'ya pas c'est pas les jeux type
warcraft ou ce genre de choses il ya
comme des beaucoup de règles à apprendre
beaucoup de choses données comme sont
des jeux très simples d'accord où tout
le monde peut jouer que ce soit les
petits il est
les parents les ados les grands et
grands parents et ses mystères à poissy
est vendu dans une boutique de jeux de
société à poissy également sur le site
internet jacques amitié jeu.fr où
environ une dizaine de jeu est proposé
comme l g un jeu de stratégie
je me suis beaucoup amusé à créer des
règles et j'ai eu on a fait beaucoup de
réduire de plateaux différents ça c'est
parti dans tous les sens et au final on
ne trouve un plateau qui est moi je le
trouve magnifique avec des règles un peu
alors certes les règles sont un peu
compliquées plus que de nos autres jeux
des jeux diverses et variées pour tous
les goûts et tous les âges prochains
jeux de société à l'étude pour cette
famille décliner mystère a dans d'autres
villes yvelinoise